[Music]
i want to welcome you all to the 2021
ibm quantum summit
this is our flagship invitation only
event for the quantum computing
community bringing together the
brightest minds in quantum computing to
hear industry defining launches
announcements and perspectives on this
remarkable emerging technology
before i get started talking about our
technical roadmap i want to take a step
back just to remind us why we're all
doing this it's been said before but it
bears repeating
we need to take better care of this
thing
we need to feed and provide more energy
for our growing populations
while at the same time
we need to reduce the effects of climate
change
we have to stabilize volatile global
economies and create more economic
opportunities for all
we have to counter emergent viruses and
bacteria
we can't tackle these big problems by
plugging away with the same tools that
we've been using for decades
classical computing
incredible as it is is not enough now
and will never be
we need something new
and now we think we are getting close
today as daario announced just a few
minutes ago we broke the 100 cupid
barrier with our 127 cubit eagle
processor
this is huge
computationally speaking we are in
uncharted territory and that's very
exciting
the first thing you do in unshaded
territory is make a map so that's
exactly what we did back in february of
this year
back in february we shared our
development roadmap this is our detailed
plan to reach frictionless quantum
computing using over a thousand qubits
and we still plan to do this by the end
of 2023
now anyone can say they have a plan to
do stuff
the hard part is doing it this is the
difference between having a plan and a
wish list so let's see what we've been
able to achieve this year in february we
said we would demonstrate a hundred fold
increase in performance with kiskit
runtime
in may we just did that in fact we got a
120 fold increase
we also said we would launch our 127
qubit chip in 2021 and we've just done
that
breaking the hundred qubit barrier is
important for many reasons we see that
it marks a turning point in the
development of quantum computing
we're no longer just focused on scale
and quality of qubits
we can now focus on the useful work
those qubits can do
in other words we can start to talk
about performance
we measure performance with three key
metrics and we must keep improving all
of them all the time
first we have scale
increasing the number of qubits in our
systems is critical it determines the
size of the problems we can compute our
ability to scale is related to
capabilities with our hardware
technology and ibm has had a long
history leading the world in this
we must continue investing in the
hardware technology to ensure we advance
every year the second is quality
this is a measure of how good our
technology is at implementing quantum we
currently measure this using quantum
volume which is a benchmark we
introduced to the industry in 2017 and
it has been adopted widely and finally
we have speed
this is a measure of how fast our
systems can solve a problem we need to
be able to solve useful problems in a
reasonable time or we do not have a
business
so we measure this by qpu speed
and we'll talk more about this later
let's start with scale let's dive into
more details about how we broke the
hundred qubit barrier with eagle and how
we're going to keep driving scale over
the coming years
i'd like to welcome jerry to the stage
to tell us all about it
aj
thanks a lot jay uh last year we shared
our aggressive industry pace setting
development roadmap
committing to scaling our quantum
systems each year we named our quantum
hardware system generations after
well-known birds so we first delivered
falcon at 27 cubits to you all two years
ago and then at last year's quantum
summit we released our hummingbird
processor at 65 cubits by the way we
haven't chosen these targets in scaling
qubit number arbitrarily in fact the
roadmap is fully aligned with the
development of critical enabling
technologies along each step much like
the technology nodes that resulted in
semiconductor roadmap processor
generations now here i'd like to
showcase the core technologies that
we're driving
that the critical enablers of each
processor family with falcon our
challenge was reliable yield
we met that challenge with a novel
precision joseph's injunction tuning
process combined with our collision
reducing heavy hexagonal lattice then
with hummingbird we implemented a large
ratio multiplex readout allowing us to
bring down the total cryogenic
infrastructure needed for qubit state
readout by a factor of eight now this
reduced the raw amount of componentry
needed inside the craftstead and now
with eagle we've continued to leverage
ibm's hard technology
this is something very deeply rooted in
our history eagle was born out of a
necessity to scale up the way that we do
our device packaging so that we can
bring signals to and from our
superconnecting qubits in a much more
efficient way our work to achieve this
is relied heavily upon ibm's experience
with cmos technology
and this includes through substrate vias
and multi-level wiring technology
now here's a visual of what our eagle
processor looks like it's two chips the
joseph and junction based super
connecting transmon sit on one chip and
is attached to a separate interposer
chip through bump bonds
this interposer chip provides the much
needed connections to the cubist through
the packaging techniques which are
common throughout the cmos world and
these include things like substrate vias
and a buried wiring layer which is
completely novel for this technology and
the presence of that buried layer gives
us tremendous flexibility in terms of
routing the signals and laying out of
the device
i can categorically say that this is the
most advanced quantum computing chip
ever built in fact not only has it been
built
but our eagle has landed this is the
world's first quantum processor over 100
cubits and for that matter it has 127
cubits arranged in our now well-known
heavy hexagonal lattice
and let me stress this isn't just a
processor we've fabricated
but a full working system that is
running quantum circuits today
here's the device map for ibm washington
currently deployed
and it is an exploratory system that the
team is currently busy putting through
its paces with calibrations and
benchmarks
and in fact here's a circuit that jay
actually just ran this morning showing
entanglement across four qubits now i
know our partners clients and the rest
of the world are dying to get their
hands on this
and our plan is to have eagle widely
available at the end of the year
and most importantly we are on track
with our hardware road bat we said we
give you falcon and we did that
we said we'd give you hummingbird and we
did that
we said we get you eagle and here we are
now we next plan to scale to 433 qubits
with our ibm osprey processor in 2022
and for this the team is already hard at
work with the next generation of
scalable input output that can deliver
signals from room temperature to the
cryogenic temperatures
we're on track
back to you jay
thanks jerry
as i said quality is a measure of how
good our technology is at implementing
quantum
this includes effects like material loss
and other imperfections as well as
control and readout errors
we measure this with a metric we
introduced to the world in 2017 called
quantum volume
and since then we set ourselves the goal
of doubling our quantum volume every
year
so far we've doubled it every year and
we currently have a quantum volume of
128.
to continue at this pace we need a
constant drum beat of scientific
breakthroughs
so here to explain these is mathias
steffen matthias
hey jerry are you
jay thank you
today i really would like to highlight
major progress on the first two topics
coherence and gate fidelity
as a result of many hard hours of work
and ingenuity we've had a breakthrough
with our new falcon r8 processors
we have succeeded in improving our qubit
t1 times dramatically from about 0.1
milliseconds to 0.3 milliseconds
this breakthrough is not limited to one
off chip it has now been repeated
several times
in fact some of our clients may have
noticed the device map showing up for
ibm peak skill recently
this is just a start
we have tested several research test
devices and we're now measuring 0.6
milliseconds closing in on reliably
crossing the one millisecond barrier we
have also had a breakthrough this year
with improved gate fidelities
here you can see these improvements
color coded by device family
our falcon r4 devices generally achieved
gate errors near 0.5 times 10 to the
minus 3.
our falcon r5 devices that also include
faster readout are about one-third
better in fact many of our recent
demonstrations came from this r5 device
family
finally in gold you see some of our
latest test devices which include falcon
r8 with the improved coherence times you
also see several other measured gauge
fidelities for other devices including
our very recently falcon r10 falcon r10
is very exciting
as we have measured a 2q gate breaking
the
0.001 error per gate plane so now in
addition to the announcement that we've
broken the 100 cubit barrier with eagle
we have a second major announcement
we're proud to say in recent weeks we've
broken the 0.001
error per gate barrier
we're now below that
0.001 which corresponds to over 1 000
gates per error
we look forward to continued progress
over the coming months
thank you
and back to you jay
thank you matthias
as quantum computing evolves and we see
even greater improvements in scale and
quality we start to care more about the
useful work our systems can do in a
reasonable time if we measure scale by
the number of qubits and quality by the
quantum volume then quantum processing
speed is a measure of the useful work
those qubits can do in a reasonable time
we define it as the number of primitive
circuits that can be processed in a
second
similar to flops in classical computing
the number of floating point operations
per second improving qpu speed is key to
practical quantum computing
so with that i'd like to introduce katie
to the stage to take us through our news
here
katie thanks jay jerry
as jay mentioned as quantum evolves we
start to care about useful work our
systems can do in a reasonable amount of
time
there's no getting away from it useful
quantum computing requires running lots
of circuits most applications require
running at least a billion
so if it takes my system more than 5
milliseconds to run a circuit it's
simple math a billion circuits will take
you 58 days that's not useful quantum
computing that's practically waiting
between halloween to new year's eve
so increasing the qpu speed is essential
for bringing practicality to quantum
computing
at the lowest level qpuspeed is driven
by the underlying architecture this is
one of the reasons we chose
superconducting qubits in these systems
we can easily couple the qubits to the
resonators in the processors
this gives us fast gates fast resets and
fast readout fundamentals for speed
take the falcon r5 processor for example
this is a huge upgrade over the falcon
r4 with the r5 we integrated new
components into the processor that have
eight times stronger measurement rate
than the r4 without any effect on
coherence
this allows the measurement rate to be a
few hundred nanoseconds compared to a
few microseconds add this to the other
improvements we've made to gate time and
you have a major step forward with the
falcon r5 so this would make our third
major announcement today
in addition to breaking the 100 cubit
barrier with eagle and the three nines
gate error rate matt just talked about
we're officially moving from falcon r5
from our exploratory system to a core
system that's right we know our users
have been dying to get their hands on
this system now they can
with stable reliable falcon r5
technology as the core we're really
looking forward to seeing what our users
and partners can do with all this extra
performance in 2016 when we put the
first quantum computer on the cloud we
created a simple programming model where
circuits could be sent directly to the
quantum computer this was really all
that was needed when quantum computing
was just starting out
but this architecture only allows the
qpu to work at five to ten percent
efficiency
a gpu works with a cpu and runtime
software to fully utilize its power we
see our qpu's working exactly the same
way to get the most out of quantum
processors we need to bring some
classical computing close to the qpu in
may we release the kiskit runtime in
beta
we created kiskit runtime to be the
container platform for executing
classical codes in an environment that
has very fast access to quantum hardware
in fact kiskit runtime completely
changes the use model for quantum
hardware
it allows users to submit programs of
circuits rather than simply circuits to
ibm's quantum data centers this approach
gives us 120 fold improvement in
performance overnight a program like the
qe which used to take our users 45 days
to run can now be done in nine hours
this leap forward and performance
combined with our 127 cubit eagle
processor means that from this point on
no one really needs to use the simulator
anymore so our fourth major announcement
today is that all of our devices now
support kiz kit runtime now everybody
can take advantage of our untouchable
quantum performance back to you jay
thanks katie
so that's another step in our roadmap
checked off
to summarize in order for adoption to
accelerate we need to also focus on the
useful work quantum computers can do we
define this as performance and it's a
combination of scale quality and speed
in order to be successful we need to
constantly improve all three and so far
this year we've done just that
but there's a bigger story here
as we take quantum computing out of the
lab and create a real business we have
to look at the value we create for our
clients this is driven heavily by
performance we can offer our clients but
it's not the only thing
of course being scientists and engineers
we love equations so here's another one
for you we see client value as being
driven by a combination of performance
which we already talked about
plus the capabilities of the system by
capabilities we mean the things that
quantum computers can do to move us
towards quantum advantage things like
error mitigation circuit knitting and
other fun stuff we're going to talk
about in a minute
the other variable that drives client
value is ease of delivery and use or
what we call frictionless our aim is to
effectively eliminate all barriers to
adoption and usage
making quantum computing work the way
the world already works so next i want
to introduce sarah shelton to the stage
to talk about our recent development in
capabilities
welcome sarah
hey jay hi jerry
as katie mentioned we're seeing amazing
results by using powerful combinations
of classical and quantum resources what
katie described involves squeezing more
performance from our qpu at the circuit
level by combining it with classical
resources to remove latency and increase
efficiency we call this classical with a
little c
but that's not the whole story we've
also discovered we can use classical
resources to accelerate progress towards
quantum advantage and get us there
earlier
in other words to drive the development
of our system capabilities to do this we
use something we call using classical
with a capital c
and this is what i want to talk about
today this year we are diving into
research into capabilities which is
earlier than we'd first planned these
capabilities will be both at the kernel
and algorithm levels we see them as a
set of tools allowing users to trade off
quantum and classical resources to
optimize the overall performance of an
application at the kernel level this
will be achieved using libraries of
circuits for sampling time evolution and
more but at the algorithm level this is
where it's getting exciting we see a
future where we're offering pre-built
kiskit runtimes in conjunction with
classical integration libraries
let's look at these capabilities more
closely we call this circuit knitting
this class of techniques decomposes a
large quantum circuit with more qubits
and larger gate depth into multiple
smaller quantum circuits with fewer
qubits and smaller gate depths then it
combines the outcomes together in
classical post-processing this allows us
to simulate much larger systems than
ever before
we can also knit together circuits along
an edge where a high level of noise or
crosstalk would be present this lets us
simulate quantum systems with higher
levels of accuracy this year we
demonstrated circuit knitting by
simulating the ground state of a water
molecule using only five qubits with the
specific technique of entanglement
forging which knits circuits across
weakly entangled halves with circuit
knitting we can boost the scale of the
problem we can solve or the quality of
the result by trading off our speed so
for this reason and many others we need
to have an excess of speed and that's
exactly what kiss kit runtime gives us
by maximizing the utilization of our
fast superconducting quantum processors
here are some other examples with
dynamic circuits we use mid-circuit
measurement and feed forward to reduce
the depth of a circuit through short
depth preparation of entangled states
dynamic circuits also enable more
efficient use of qubits by freeing them
up for reuse
so the quality scale and speed of the
circuit can all be boosted there is no
trade-off
for all these reasons we see a huge role
for dynamic circuits they are one of the
major steps on our roadmap for next year
air mitigation techniques use additional
quantum circuits that either amplify the
noise as shown here or calibrate the
noise followed by a classical
computation that finds the mitigated
expectation value both error mitigation
and circuit knitting borrow from the
speed bucket in order to boost the scale
of the problem that can be addressed
or boost the quality of the results as
we look to the future we will continue
to explore these trade-offs by borrowing
from scale to encode logical qubits from
physical qubits and implement
error-corrected circuits the plan is to
combine all of these capabilities to
optimize the performance as our quantum
systems keep improving
back to you jay
thanks sir
now i want to share some exciting news
about what we call frictionless let's
bring katie back to talk more about this
katie
so this brings us to our fifth
announcement for today today we
announced quantum serverless the next
step for kiskit runtime
quantum serverless will allow us to
incorporate all of the advanced
capabilities sarah just covered into a
simple developer experience with all the
speed and flexibility you already have
with kizkit runtime
as a developer or researcher you should
not have to set up classical resources
you want to focus on the code not the
infrastructure not the servers not the
container management and any of that
stuff you want the classical resources
to scale inherently when you need them
but pay for only what you use and you
still want the flexibility to change
your code and select whatever classical
hardware you want to work with whether
it's hvc
gpus or whatever
so in partnership with ibm cloud we're
going to now show you an example with
code engine and how it can be combined
with quantum computing to make quantum
serverless a reality the first step is
to define the problem in this case we're
using vqe
secondly we use lithops a python
multi-cloud distributed computing
framework to execute the code inside
this function we open a communication
channel to the kiskit runtime and run
the program estimator
as an example for the classical
computation we use the simultaneous
perturbation stochastic approximation
algorithm this is just an example you
could put anything here
so now the user can just sit back and
enjoy the results
as quantum is increasingly adopted by
developers quantum serverless enables
developers to just focus on their code
without getting dragged into configuring
classical resources they'll have more
time be more productive and have more
opportunity to iterate towards success
back to you jay thanks again katie
we've completed our roadmap for 2021.
we're also on track for our goals for
2022 and we are confident that in 2023
will be an important year
simply put after 2023 assuming we
continue at the same rate
we are in the land of quantum advantage
we say that land because we don't think
quantum advantage will be a fixed point
in time or a specific event
we see it more as a continuum where
applications start off abstract and
esoteric and become slowly more useful
over time so coming back to our value
equation if we have a pretty clear idea
of our performance our capabilities and
the barriers to entry and adoption then
we should be able to start to
extrapolate client value going forward
so i'd like to introduce our friend matt
from the boston consulting group to join
us on stage over to you matt
i'm matt langone principal at the boston
consulting group and one of the leaders
in our deep tech mission
over the past three years we at bcg have
had hundreds of conversations with
potential end users of quantum computing
in boardrooms out in the field in
government labs
we've worked hand-in-hand to find
high-value use cases for quantum
computers when they mature
but the natural follow-up question when
in fact will they mature has been too
difficult to answer with the right level
of specificity until now
the new roadmap that ibm has laid out
allows us to chart a path to value that
ties the computational complexity of
real industry use cases to specific
milestones in solution maturity that
will play out over the next few years
the results are very very promising
ibm's roadmap is not just concrete it's
also ambitious
we think the technical capabilities that
jn team have outlined today will help
create three billion dollars in value
for end users during the period
described
and they set the groundwork for much
more to come
take financial services where portfolio
optimization is limited today by the
type of constraints that classical
optimizers can handle at scale
they struggle with non-continuous
non-convex functions things like
interest rate yield curves trading lots
buy-in thresholds transaction costs
adding these constraints to the
calculation makes the optimization
surface too complex for classical
optimizers but it also improves trading
strategies by as much as 25 basis points
with gate fidelity at four nines by 2024
with run times that integrate classical
resources and have error mitigation
built in we believe this is the sort of
capability that could be in trader
workflows by 2025 so too for the mesh
optimizers that power computational
fluid dynamics for aerospace and
automotive design
in the next three years quantum
computers could already start powering
past node limits that constrain surface
size and accuracy today
ibm can't do it alone it'll take an
entire ecosystem to specify high-value
problems and design the right solutions
but a concrete roadmap like this gives
developers business leaders and
investors confidence that the engine
that powers it all
is only getting stronger and stronger
thanks matt thanks jay
the future is looking good and not as
far away as we once thought with all
this talk of the future it's easy to
forget that quantum computing is already
firmly here in the present
as of today we have quantum system ones
deployed across three continents
with 22 systems in our data center in
york alone this year we launched quantum
system one in fraunhofer in germany and
then again a few months later at the
university of tokyo in japan since
installation both sites have activated
their local ecosystems scientists are
doing novel research customers are being
signed up adoption and usage numbers are
up by a factor of 10. we are also very
excited about our work with cleveland
clinic which will be our first managed
quantum system installed in a private
company
and finally with the recent news about
our partnership with yonsei i am
confident more scientists using these
machines more capabilities will be
discovered and more applications of
quantum computing will emerge one of the
most challenging aspects of quantum
computing is balancing the needs of the
present with those of the future the
years of 2024 and beyond will be a
strange unpredictable world
there will be a cambrian explosion of
demand for different configurations of
quantum systems
so the success of the applications of
quantum computing will not be defined by
a singular standalone system like the
ibm quantum system one we've designed
quantum system 2 to fit into this
dynamic evolving future it's less of a
system than a modular architecture
designed to scale and fit the needs of
many different future requirements
so finally i'd like to hand over to
jerry to give us a glimpse of the future
over to you jerry
thanks jay
so our quantum system one has become
iconic in terms of its look what i like
to do is actually take a step back and
ask what exactly is a quantum system and
this is where there's often a common
misconception
it's natural to just tie a system to a
set of number of qubits so i'm often
asked is system one a falcon
or is it a hummingbird
well in both cases the answer is yes
the reason is that system one is the
combination of components and wiring
within a cryogenic platform
combined with control electronics all to
support
families of processors in the case of
system one the combination of these
various technologies enable our falcon
hummingbird and stretch to handle eagle
and so really where we are today is the
closing of the chapter on quantum system
one
as we prepare for our next generation
ibm quantum system ii
we are actively working on an entirely
new set of technologies
from novel high density cryogenic
microwave flex cables
to a new generation of fpga based high
bandwidth integrated control electronics
and on top of that
i'd like to announce a really important
partnership i actually think this is
like our sixth announcement today
but ibm quantum and our partners at
blueforce together are imagining the
next generation of cryogenic
infrastructure that will help to enable
our quantum system too
today we have a special guest traveling
here all the way from finland i'd like
to introduce russell lake the quantum
technology lead for blue force to tell
you all about their newest cryogenic
platform russell
thanks jerry controlling more qubits
than ever before motivates a new way of
thinking about quantum measurement
systems starting with the cryogenic
system itself to meet these challenges
blue force introduces a new cryogenic
platform which we call
kita in finnish
kita means snowflake or crystal which
represents the hexagonal crystal-like
geometry of the platform that enables
unprecedented expandability and access
even when we create a larger platform we
maintain the same user accessibility as
with a smaller system
this is crucial
as advanced quantum hardware scales up
we optimize cooling power by separating
the cooling for the quantum processor
from the operational heat loads and in
addition the six-fold symmetry of the
kita platform means that systems can be
joined and clustered to enable vastly
expanded quantum hardware configurations
blueforce presents kita as the platform
that will meet the new requirements for
cryogenics especially on ibm's quantum
road map
back to you jerry
thank you russell
so all these pieces the novel wiring
inside the evolved control electronics
and the world's most advanced commercial
cryogenic platform are all going to
combine to create our future systems
here is our design concept rendering for
our ibm quantum system 2
which we're designing right now
to house quantum processors such as
condor
thanks jerry
as you can start to imagine the modular
nature of ibm quantum system 2 will be
the cornerstone of the future quantum
data centers
as i said at the start this is huge
we've made a lot of announcements this
year one we've broken the 100 cubit
barrier which puts us into uncharted
territory
two we've broken the gate error barrier
three we're bringing falcon r5 from
exploratory to our core systems
four all of our systems now support
kiskat runtime
five we introduced quantum serverless
and six we've shared our plans for
quantum system 2 and our partnership
with blue force
we have 433 qubits planned for next year
and over a thousand cubits the year
after
and it's not just scale we've taken
tremendous strides forward in
performance through increases in qpe
speed and quality this year and we're
planning even bigger strides next year
dynamic circuits are a big deal they'll
bring the power of real-time classical
computations to circuits and as sarah
said they will improve performance in a
myriad of ways
and we will have more to say on this
soon we've seen tremendous growth in
both capabilities and frictionless
programming
all of these drive value for our users
with our friends from boston consulting
group painting a very promising future
the theme of this year's quantum summit
is new dimensions
and we chose that theme for a good
reason
our dream is to be able to create
machines that compute higher dimensional
mathematics at scale so we can start to
tackle some of our biggest challenges
it's no longer a dream it's a
destination and we're on our way
thank you
[Music]